hi guys I'm Eric Voss and this is a
breakdown of The Walking Dead Season
eight episode 14 still gotta mean
something and I'll tell you what means
something
Rick's murder code it's back y'all don't
talk Darren was shown I found my own
killing jacket it wants blood it tells
me to kill I'll get to the significance
of this coat and all the interesting
nods to past episodes and details that
you might have missed but first let's
start with the big questions that you
guys had first Tom on Twitter asked who
didn't Egan pickup at the end yes
the biggest mystery cliffhanger this
episode left us with was the identity of
the hitchhiker negan found on the side
of the road he said holy hell chicken's
still wooden lookers is you get in then
he brings this person back to the
sanctuary where he tells the Savior's to
keep this return a secret for now
mmm so a few people online have
speculated that this could be Gregory
saying that he appeared in promo images
for next episode at the sanctuary then
again there's also a shot in the promo
for episode 15 that shows Gregory back
at the hilltop hmm so even though
Gregory escaped from the hilltop last
episode and he wasn't with the Savior's
in the bar this episode suggested he's
on his own somewhere I do not think he
is with negan in the car here why would
negan use Gregory to surprise Simon
earth Dwight I'm back boys and surprise
witness some jerk nobody cares about
smart money in my opinion is on Laura
the missing Savior from episode 8 the
one loose end that knows the truth of
Dwight's treason that would set up an
interesting lesser of two evils debate
between Dwight and Simon Dwight played
both sides sure but Simon straight-up
defied Meighan by killing all the
scavengers and he let Rick Ram negan a
few episodes back negan can't execute
both his disloyal lieutenants canny well
I guess he could he's got a mad
scientist making bullets for him so who
cares I have another long shot guessed
that this could be Sheree Dwight's wife
wife she's sometimes known to remember
she ran away from the sanctuary in
season seven and she has not shown up
since I could also see her as a surprise
bargaining chip that negan could use
against white then again notice how
negan doesn't really have to force this
person to get in the car
not really holding them by gunpoint
maybe they're too weak to fight back but
yeah as a fugitive sherry would
definitely try to run here okay let's
move on to another big question that you
guys asked about brought to us on
Twitter by Samantha what's up with the
helicopter yes arguably an even bigger
mystery the return of the helicopter
that Rick saw earlier this season on the
way to the landfill a few episodes ago
Simon reminded us that Jadis had a
helicopter pad and now two and two came
together jatis was hoping to get
airlifted away by this helicopter which
turned back when they didn't see her
flare she had been checking her watch
all day but the scuffle with negan led
to the helicopter missing her it's clear
now that this helicopter does not belong
to Jadis she made that landing pad so
these other people could have placed to
land but who does it belong to
best guess Georgie the new group that we
got introduced to two episodes back it
was hinted that this group was way more
advanced than the other ones we've seen
and I speculated then that they could be
the actual owners of the helicopter so
here's my assumption of what Jada says
plan was this episode first fake dead to
escape the savior Massacre and then that
led to her grinding her former friends
and a minced meat which we saw a few
episodes back then break out and capture
negan then contact Georgie's people to
come get her check out her a quija type
bedroom here there is a radio on the
stool I'm guessing that's how she
reached out to them and yeah it's a
little surprising to see Jadis had this
tidy abode but we've seen her pull
supplies out of hidden compartments in
the trash before so I think we could all
guess that this whole heap was just a
front for a real home vegan comments
early on that he can smell that
something went down there that smell is
probably the rotting scavenger minced
meat that I mentioned I think Jadis has
tried to burn off that smell with salts
kind of like an incense air freshener to
hide the fact from the helicopter people
that she ground up everyone because you
know let's be honest even want to hang
out with someone who did that what you
and Jadis through Meegan's bad on the
fire for justice against her murdered
friends then I think Jadis planned to
deliver negan perhaps as a quote
resource to Georgie maybe Georgie has
some past bad blood with negan or maybe
Georgiy once negan is like a gift to
Maggie to further earn Maggie's
inter-community cooperation and maybe
the points of Winslow the third on the
cart was to keep negan under control
during this handoff or maybe she really
did plan to kill him slowly
who knows guys I think Jadis just thinks
machine walkers look cool and if I'm
right about Georgie owning the
helicopter we'll see what their
relationship is maybe their family and
Jadis is like an outcast a black sheep
or maybe all those art sculptures that
we've seen Jadis making in the past were
part of her bartering with Georgie the
way Georgie wanted the music records
from Maggie
unfortunately for Jadis negan threw a
wrench into whatever she was planning
she clearly didn't tie him up tightly
enough look closely at his hands and he
can see that he definitely could wriggle
himself out of that though I agree with
a lot of you I was initially confused as
hell when negan suddenly appeared
unrestrained with the gun and flare I
thought my recording had skipped her
something honestly I think it was an
editing and she with the episode anyway
negan lights the flare to threaten Jay
das's photographs gonna burn them he
recognizes that they have as much
sentimental value to her as his VAT
Lucille dust to him negan actually makes
a big confession this episode that he
named Lucille after his dead wife and
that the bat represents his last
remaining connection to ur so Jadis
recognizes that commonality between them
and after missing the boat with the
helicopter she decides she doesn't need
to go through with her plans for negan
her memories of her friends are too
important to her and she lets go which I
still think is a pretty dumb move but
we'll see what this good will between
the two of them leads to okay let's move
on because this episode was full of
really interesting connections to past
episodes so let's review them all in our
segment callbacks okay early on Ezekiel
tells Carol to keep the faith about
Henry reminding her you told me to
pretend to make it real until it is so
this is a callback to early in season 7
the first real conversation between
these two when they discussed why they
hide behind their fake personas they
realized then that illusion can become
reality
if it helps you deal with the hardships
of this world meanwhile later Carol
reminded Morgan about
during this time saying when I tried to
run you found me she's referencing the
end of season six when Carol started to
freak out at her own killing streak and
Morgan brought her to the kingdom except
now he's the crazy one I like that a
little callback Jarret actually makes
later on reminding us that Morgan
strangled his own guy with his own hands
he's referring to Richard who Morgan
killed because Richard planned to avenge
Benjamin
even though Morgan just avenged Benjamin
this episode guys Morgan is all over the
place I feel bad for the group on fear
The Walking Dead they're gonna be like
couldn't you have given us Daryl really
the coolest callback this episode
involves Carol when she finds Henry the
location with the branches over the
creek is the same location that they
used in season two when Rick hid Sophia
under the branches and he led the
walkers away from her they checked back
later and Sophia was gone now this isn't
the same location in the world of the
show that was down in Georgia this is up
in Virginia but it's clear this was
intended to be a parallel moment for
Carol emotionally speaking since losing
Sophia she has always been cursed in the
form of the children around her dying
finding Henry in a similar hiding place
that Sophia wasn't inside must be hugely
therapeutic for her it also helps that
the actor who plays Henry is a real-life
little brother to the actor who played
Sophia
it's like Sophia went into this tree
fort vanished a few years later came
back out as a boy yeah actually you know
what don't look it that way Carol that
might mess you up even more we also got
confirmation this episode that Dwight
did indeed shoot Tara with a clean arrow
proving his loyalty in her eyes and I
love Daryl doubting her logic saying
it's not like a bite sometimes nothing
happens now I saw this as a meta
explanation trying to clarify our
confusion over this whole exposure to
Walker blood can infect you nonsense
Daryl's like damn I've been licking
Walker blood off my arrows for eight
seasons now and I feel fine who knows
how this works this episode also reminds
us of the letters that Carl wrote for
all of them
notice Rick's face when he walks in on
Michonne reading hers he clearly didn't
want her to read it now he's annoyed
that she'll bug him about the letters
that Carl wrote Rick and to negan
essentially Michonne has become the
executor
of Karl's estate Michonne makes another
call back to Andrea saying that Andrea
helped her move on from the loss of her
son by actually dealing with her grief
and that was shown now intends to do
that for Rick later while sitting with
Judith Rick's stares at the hat that he
gave Karl that's sitting on top of this
duffel bag this hat symbolizes both
Rick's relationship with Karl but also
his responsibility as a lawman he's
struggling to follow in quarrels moral
footsteps or maybe he Ric just thinks
Karl turned into a duffel bag you're a
dolphin Karl my boys a duffel bag but
instead of the Hat Rick goes are the
different wardrobe murderer oh no no no
no no doom now just to remind you the
history here
this was the coat Rick wore when he
executed Pete at the end of season 5 and
he worked throughout two memorable
killings in season six at the hilltop
when he stabbed that guy in the neck and
then stood up and asked would then the
next episode and the satellite compound
when he murdered dozens of Savior's in
their sleep and then after that when he
murdered the Savior while saving Carol
and Maggie and through all of that blood
somehow the fur collar never got stained
this coat is evil guys Rick stopped
wearing it after negan killed Glenn and
Abraham but now for the first time ever
he puts it back on and it's really
interesting to see how it reflects his
dark turn this episode I've talked
before about how he and negan have
swapped kind of as hero and villain and
that trend continues this episode his
betrayal of the Savior's and the bar is
straight-up cold and may remind you of
the dick move he pulled on Todd earlier
this season promising not to hurt him
after the kid would come out from behind
the tree and just shooting him anyway
it's also worth comparing this scenario
to negan and Gabriel earlier this season
those two foes were surrounded by
walkers and had to work together to get
out and meeting kept his word allowing
Gabriel to recover in the sanctuary
clinic now how does Rick thank the
Savior's for cutting him loose and
collaborating together and clearing
these Walker's murder code Dachau I just
think the point of this savagery is to
connect Rick with Morgan it's
interesting to see these two men working
together again consider
this is how The Walking Dead series
began and now we can see how far they've
come Rick makes another little call back
when he has to remind Morgan you know me
this recalls the clear episode in season
3 when rick has to talk Morgan down the
same way Morgan also makes the call back
to the clear episode when he tells Henry
at the end of the episode don't ever be
sorry he says those same words to Carl
in the clear episode by the way did
anyone else think Morgan was about to
snap Henry's neck here for a second he
like grabs his collar like a little jerk
I must clear you but then it's all
smiles I killed the guy who won the dead
are you happy but the most crucial line
comes in the callback that Morgan makes
to the pilot episode when Rick asks him
why he saved him and Morgan responds
because my son was there Rick realizes
in this moment how far down the dark
path the loss of Dwayne took Morgan he
realizes that Michonne was right if he
doesn't properly deal with his son's
death he'll devolve into the violent
psychopath that Morgan has become which
leads us to the deeper meaning of this
episode titled still gotta mean
something it's a reference to Rick
giving his word to the Savior's which
turned out to be a very empty promise
but Rick's seeing the danger of this
kind of behavior from Morgan leads him
to step back from this extreme the
cinematography actually illustrates this
with these shots of Rick through mirrors
early in the episode before pulling
Carl's letter out of the drawer he faces
the mirror but we don't see his
reflection in it it's like he cannot yet
face himself in his own grief later
after Morgan makes him question his ways
Rick sees his reflection but it's in a
shattered mirror referencing his broken
soul in this moment but in the final
image of the episode Rick finally reads
Carl's letter which we see through the
reflection in its bedroom mirror a
reflection hole once more finally
understanding that his son's post-mortem
words still gotta mean something the
comparison between Rick and Morgan is
also reflected in this week's kill count
Rick technically had the most kills at 9
but most of those were walkers he only
killed two Savior's whereas Morgan kills
for human saviors and for walkers making
him deadlier in my book Morgan's staring
at Jarrod in the eyes her behind the
gate was especially haunting actor
Linney James said that the script called
for his emotion to
passive and his passivity at watching
this hated enemy die slowly reminded me
a little of Eastman in season six who
told Morgan that he created that prison
cell in his place for the murderer of
his family to watch him slowly die but
whereas Eastman took the path of peace
from that experience
Morgan has definitely done the opposite
so here's my question for you guys was
it Carl's death that changed Rick into
the villain he is now or has Rick always
been this way
after all when Rick shot that Todd guy
it was before Karl died maybe the murder
code was inside I want to know your
thoughts our guys comment down below or
tweet me directly I da vas and follow
new rock stars on Twitter for updates on
our videos and like this video and
subscribe to do rockstars for all of our
Walking Dead coverage yeah go definitely
check out my breakdowns for all the past
episodes of season 4 the explanations of
stuff that you missed guys thanks for
watching see you next week bye